you
hi everyone it's Jerry I have another
endgame composition to share with you
this one was composed over a century ago
1915 by Frederic Lazar it's white to
move and as usual I encourage you to
spend some time with these maybe away
from the computer screen and see if you
can find the best continuation okay the
solution well actually before I share
the solution let me point out what is
not a good attempt something that you
have to kind of test out when trying to
solve it
King b7 is not a good approach because
after Bishop b4 the pawn is pinned to
the king king c7 Bishop takes pawn King
d7 in his pawn is just too fast you just
you know you're not going to catch it
and there's no there's no fancy tricks
involved black is just going to be able
to get a queen and go on to win the idea
here is which one of these two squares
to make use of the idea is to go to be a
ton move one important detail to
sidestep this pin of the pawn why is
this important well after Bishop eform
doing something else like moving the
King whenever the King moves this pawn
is able to move and it frees the bishop
this will be a simple draw so black has
to go hunting for this pawn by way of
Bishop efore and now in a very important
moment the move d6 we'll see the the
significance of this shortly basically
converting this pawn the e pawn do a
deep on and now from here the idea is to
hunt down this pawn let's see how things
are different working with now ad pawn
instead of an e pawn black has to
continually push this pawn because if
the King ever is able to block hate it
it can
you know black can't make any further
progress the King would have to move at
some stage in order to maybe allow the
pawn to move I don't even think that's
the case but if the King does move you
always have this b5 advance and it frees
the bishop so black can't allow this
King to blockade has to keep pushing
white keeps approaching and after d3
another important moment the trick here
is to approach the pawn but not capture
the bishop capturing the bishop in this
case black will go on to get a queen and
there are no tricks black will go on to
win this one
the idea is to ignore the bishop play
King d4 and after d2 king c3 see the
idea here white is now up against a wall
of pawns and there's four different ways
this pawn kept remote groaning to a
queen results in stalemate promoting to
a rook same story and looking at the
minor pieces promoting to a bishop black
cannot win this same colored bishops no
progress to be made here you cannot
force checkmate and the final one the
trickiest one and go figure it's related
to the promotion of a knight black can't
win this after king here if the knight
moves king e3 will pick up one of the
minor pieces next the only way to save
the minor pieces is Bishop f3 but even
so in this position black cannot win I
can save these two but in order to try
and deliver checkmate this would mean
that the King has to help out and as
soon as the King helps out there's
always this b5 move which is going to
free the bishop to help defend in the
knight in Bishop versus King endgame
this is a drawn position
so that's the key idea first king v8 and
then converting the e pond to a deep
pond go hunting sidestep this capture
and then put the king up against this
wall for those stalemate tricks one
swipe promotes anyhow as usual feel free
to leave any feedback to this
composition in the comment section below
let me know if you've figured it out
and I hope you enjoyed it that's all for
now take care bye
you